стол місто рифт мішки з каміном на
кольє вели вони 100 бахмут на даній шині
колаж не бийте добра увійти до ж місити
блок затишок залізничний з отримання між
кола на це окуповані
територіями тут тягнув двох місцях лухан
шини та донеччини барикади заданого
організаторів акції вже за панелі 50000
вагоні не види
економічний vantage та ось все щось
бугеля метал
промислів і монтажі ж рук і магнітуди
не назад ми ось закриваємо у з нардепа
йогор соболів учасник баку vanitas пиво
автор законопроекту про купову не
території вин нагадує акція
продовжи волосся а парламент терміна
ваза барон їхню торгівлю
ми про окрім золота продажів товарів
великий активності
продажів продуктів там ще треба для
виживання
окупованих громадян україни києва
з'явилася купувати її розум чуттєвою
землі та ми пробуємо дали дозволить та
побажання праці та гуманітарна допомога
алани під контролем ринату ахметова
контролем міжнародних гуманітарних
організацій на те є і низка і президент
засудив і благ у вані йа мауля спроба
Держави крокують два мільярди
доларів соратники президент опинюся за
барона тур гинули виробляє з курорту не
робочих місць на куповій ній території
шахтарин там і дав ургеу
написано законопроект якупова не
території який знає про написана серія
там наших вибір дивним а я так давайте
їх ведмежу
будемо на думаєте про права людини там про
тих законопроектах намажать але слова про
браво люди на думку і рваний
гращенків нинішня axe аж нею атласна і
і обміну полунина ви нібито цінний
аргументу вали її організатори ще
за ручники перебувають у крим чи
з москва представник твоєї з в Україні
також застряючи був у кого не загиблий
зупиниш клацніть на окупованих
територіях
за клік la дня ти у добра і норманська
четвер а таз та сатсангів командам а наш
спиляли за клік дутих хто нині добре /
і кольє припаяні ти всю блокаду
отже ви наш подати обом сторонам як ти
їм хто хоче експортувати його villa
такет їм комуна необхідний ще продукт
ват електроенергії втрачається за раціоном
початок блокаді лягаєш за 100
шукала тью в об'єкті ти вибач гуміста
спокійно їздити покер з виділимо на
премію самопроголошеної днр в обсі
блокади
буквально як ожити дацик вулик у них
поки руками дешевий тафсирі наді йдуть
всі їхні акції про і на ці більше
людей